hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
endpoint assays for the characterization
of rare and therapy resistant cells in
cancer
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions
you may have during the presentation to
do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education
credits window i'd like to now welcome
our speaker
jordy petries group leader functional
cyatomics group
joseph carreras leukemia research
institute in barcelona spain
jordy you may now begin your
presentation
okay thank you very much for this nice
introduction first of all i would like
to thank the organizers
for inviting me and giving me the
opportunity to explain
how the how the endpoint assets that we
are developing
at the usaf card of the chemical
research institute are crucial for
the characterization of rare and
therapeutic resistance
cells in cancer
in general a typical experiment involves
four basic steps
such as the adequate sample preparation
the optimized
instruments attack the procedure of data
that acquisition and finally how we
perform
data analysis we are particularly
interested in human leukemia
and we are currently developing a new
method to both identify
healthy and leukemic stem cells stem
cells are rare
and the accurate identification of this
compartment
is crucial for human progenitor cell
counting and for monitoring minimal
measurable disease
among other practical stem cell assays
more than 20 years ago we published this
article
in nature medicine as a new technology
to identify
c34 uh positive cells in analyzed whole
blood
by using viable nucleic acid stains
we avoided droid cell lysing a procedure
that can result in leukocyte depletion
as well as detrimental for c34 positive
cells
as you can see here the first blood is
used to display
cd45 positive nucleated cells
simultaneously they meet with site 13 a
permanent nucleic
acid dye used to exclude non-nucleated
cells
a fluorescence trigger was used to
discriminate leukocytes from
erythrocytes
and after a sequential boolean gait c34
positive cells were enumerated
using the last plot counting bits are
also displayed here
and use it for absolute c34 cell
counting no lies
no wash methods are deployed when a
minimal sample perturbation
is is needed cells are directly
stained and diluted in hank's balance
solution
with no detrimental viability and
functional
effect then analyzed blood can be
analyzed after dilution
after 10-fold faster speed arrayed using
acoustic
assisted flow cytometry
leukocytes are in general numbered by
red blood cells in
approximately one thousand fold in whole
black
and generally uh require enrichment
by a regular blood cell lysis or
gradient centrifugation
prior to analysis the rapid sample
collection rates
and the inclusion of the tune and xt
flow cytometer
allow identification of leukocytes by
scatter properties alone
when using for instance the violet
side scatter laser
leukocytes even diluted earlier cells
can be easily identified using no lyso
wash
methods by using the violet laser
configuration
and they trigger for cd45 fluorescence
red blood cells are completely
discriminated c34 positive cells can be
counted
as demonstrated here providing highly
accurate and precise enumeration
as shown here even using high speed
sample rate
less than three ce34 cells per
microliter can be
detected in
this slide we have compared
identification of a c34
and leukemic cells on the left cells
were analyzed using
a conventional hydrodynamic flow
cytometer and single
laser excitation on the right the same
specimen was analyzed using
our no license or wash approach with two
laser excitation to better excite fiber
retrieving the dye we commonly use for
c34 conjugates as you can see here
there is a very good separation of
glucemic cells suggesting clonal
evolution
of the leukemic population using the
acoustic cytometer
and this novelized no wash
approach in this slide
we can see a flow cytometry analysis of
analyzed core blood as we shown here a
threshold
is set for determining a nucleate acid
leveling
and leveling whole blood life cells by
cyto 13
versus pc5 cd45 analysis
of dna rna positive events in r1
on the right forward the scatter versus
cd45 negative events are
shown in r2 and cd45 negative population
are mainly nucleated red blood cells as
is
shown here
the scatter properties of leukocytes and
nucleated red blood cells are
also shown here and on the right a new
scatter plot
is used to show a range of immature to
major
nucleated and red blood cells extruded
nuclei
are identified as a very low forward
scatter population
and low forward events mainly contain
orthochromatic erythrocytes
and nucleated red blood cells with blood
scattered pattern
are early stage erythrolysts
13 positive cd45 negative population
were then sorted on the basis of forward
the scattered properties
and prepared for microscopy analysis the
morphology of this series
was in agreement with erythrite
differentiation for merely too late to
stage a restorative
with a decrease in cell size
and i would like to show you now how
acoustic focusing take
advantage for many many applications and
particle
focusing is promising as an example
particles can be oriented easily
by simply using a specific frequencies
the particles that we are observing here
and after increasing the frequency
and as you can see here particles can be
specifically oriented based
on the frequency that we are applying
and in general higher frequencies will
provide
more complex patterns as also shown in
the present
and the two next slides
adding more complexity add the pattern
of distribution of distribution of dust
inside over this uh display and
after increasing and the frequency
of the waves that are producing this
vibration
in this magnetic base
the field of acoustic cytometry was
originally invented at the los amos
los alamos national laboratory as a way
to allow scientists to quantitate and
maximize sales
sales by passing them through a laser
based detection device
acoustic focusing enables what longer
transit times and high
throughput which simultaneously permit
better interrogation of every cell
in a sample an analysis of much larger
much larger number of cells bringing
researchers and scientists
one step closer to the precise
quantification
of molecular phenotypes at the single
cell level
the following two slides show how when
the acoustic processing is turned
off uh turn it off micro bits are
misaligned
across the capillary section
and as you can see here and the beads
are
misaligned with the focusing on
off i'm sorry and however
when acoustic focusing is turned at turn
it on particles are closely aligned
allowing optimal laser
excitation even at higher sample
rates therefore coincidence of particles
within immunized minimized when optimal
cell or particle dilutions
are used are used taking advantage for
rapid
and sensitive detection of rare cells
laura garcia ricco it was dog working in
my lab since
2015 can conducted most if not all the
experiments i will start to explain
right now as you may know like the
scatter
patterns generated from a cell size and
complexity can be used to broadly
identify different cell types
consisting predominantly of lymphocytes
monocytes and granulocytes when we are
looking at
at black
several techniques have employed
electron microscopy to the study of
blood cells
scanning microscopy in the upper row and
transmission microscopy below
provide differential information being
the last one
or specifically used to demonstrate
chromatin changes
and condensation in this
slide a representative scatter plot of
normal whole blood is shown
and as you may know forward scatter
provides information on the relative
size
of the analyzed events while study
scatter
estimates the complexity in general
monocytes are larger than lymphocytes
while neutrophils have more complexity
or granularity however
the observed classic profile results
from the overlap of different subsets
of leukocytes with different like the
scatter properties that can
you can easily identify it on a
on the acoustic flow cytometer when
appropriately
uh analyze it
now with the aim to of identifying
primitive
uh the chemical progenitor cells in in
human
leukemia we modify it an alkaline
phosphate is stem cell detection method
based on the determination of a
fluorescent alkaline velocity substrate
in cells positive for the enzyme
the original method using fluorescence
microscopy
was adapted for floyd cytometry
measurements
and the alkaline phosphate is life stain
is the proof that we have used it for
this kind of experiment
is a self permeable permeable
fluorescent substrate for
alkaline phosphates and that is not
non-toxic to cells
and diffuse over the cells after the
course of
many hours we have used this method to
identify
different subsets of c34 positive cells
based on the activity of the enzyme and
as you can see here mobilized pressure
of blood
and the leukopherosis products
were analyzed showing a representative
plots as we shown
here and
we hypothesize that c34 positive cells
with high levels of alkaline phosphatase
activity
are the more primitive progenitors and
that can be used as a potential
biomarker for
short and long term engraftment in human
transplantation after stem cell
mobilization
absolute counting of c34 positive cells
was compared and healthy donors and
multiple myeloma patients show a
different alkaline phosphate activity
as shown in the next slide
we also believe that c34 positive
alkaline phosphatase high cells
may be associated with a more primitive
stem cell-like population
being essential for long-term
engraftment whereas c4 c34 alkaline
phosphatase positive cells with the low
activity of the enzyme
may be associated with more
differentiated population
populations with short term repopulating
capacity
importantly we are optimizing c34
positive signal cell counting methods
and we are currently applying specific
improvements aimed
at the more precise progenitor cell
counting
the nxt cytometer is ready to provide
true direct volumetric counting without
bits
in addition pc34 positive cells can be
detected
after excitation with a yellow green
laser
giving optimal separation from negative
cells
this slide shows how we usually
discriminate doublets
and aggregates once the rare fraction of
cells has been
identified based on the use of nucleic
acid stains
for normalizing wash methods therefore
solution for single cell discrimination
is obtaining
is obtained when a fluorescent parameter
is
used the next
following slides will show you how
sample manipulation heavily affects
a special subcalculation of fragile
cells which are also rare
dendritic cells and vasophiles can be
identified as described
in this slide and plasmacytoid dendritic
cells
and conventional dendritic cells can be
discriminated based
on based on the positivity and negative
negativity of
cd 123 and cd11c
markers this slide show the results we
have obtained using the nolahs no wash
approach and a dime channel was used to
discriminate lineage negative cells and
then plot it again
to both identify vasofills and the two
type
of dendritic cells this was
done using the knowledge no wash method
and this
this reference method was compared with
different lysine solutions
such as cylinders
opticalized solution and
pharma a non-fixative ammonium chloride
based solution and as you can see here
there are important differences
in the resolution and the scatter
properties of
the populations that we are analyzing
and just
to show you how this slide summarizes
the four methods
we have compared showing a
representative applies for dendritic
cell counting
values displayed here represent the
absolute numbers of dendritic cells
obtain it for a comparison using the no
lysone or wash method
the cylinders the optilize and the
ammonium
chloride lysine solution
when then we then analyze it and compare
the numbers of conventional dendritic
cells
the number of capacitor cycloid
deteriorating cells and muscle filters
showing that
red sterilizing is heavily affecting the
absolute counting
of the of these rare cells as i take
home a message for this part of my talk
i would like to conclude that
rectalizing methods should be avoided if
possible making feasible
the detection of rare cells even using
diluted and analyzed whole blood
specimens many of the experiments
performed
in in our laboratory are functional
basic assays
after sample reception blood cells are
immediately
immediately prepared for flow cytometry
analysis
in as little time as possible over
periods of one year we have been using
this technique to study its activity in
patients
with leukemia and lymphoma showing that
changes in the alkaline prostate is
level
levels can be used to detect rare
population of
refractory malignant cells
there is shown one year history for my
follow-up
of one patient a
we publish this results in in this
article in 2016
and this patient had 27
27 years old was a female diagnosed in
march 2010 with a common acute
lymphoblastic leukemia
with a normal karyotype antigen
expression was evaluated at 30 labs
showing
40 of c34 blast cells with
identical phenotype of refractory
disease as compared with diagnosis
red silk red circles shown here
indicate the bone marrow flow cytometric
analysis to detect
alkaline phosphatase activity in
combination with a silicary for positive
staining
the alkaline phosphatase test was
adapted from previously
describing methods and only was used to
determine
the alkaline phosphatase activity when
was
internally validated
this slide is and the following
will show you how the presence of
apparently clonal populations
do not just does not necessarily
represent
clonal neoplasia upper and lower panels
display comparative phenotypes at
diagnosis
and first relapse respectively
whereas this slide is used to display
comparative phenotype
at second entire relapse respectively
as shown here a phenotype of arm
apparently clonal
you cannot tell cells was based on cd10
cd19
ca 33 ca34 and cd66c positive expression
one possible explanation for the
amplification of the
apparently monoclonal economic cell is
clonal evolution
and pre-existing resistance at clones
could also explain cases arising from
very rare premalignant
hematopoietic cells constituting a
potential cellular
reservoir that may play a key role in
continuously seeing
relapsed disease
the alkaline phosphatase assay was
internally validated and was used over
the last year of treatment of this
patient
five bone marrow spirits specimens were
taken from may 2015
to april 2016 and by using the alkaline
phosphatase i'd say our results suggest
that the upper and clonal leukemic
refractory
cells can be classified into functional
into functional states
based upon the different activity those
activities level activity levels
of the facilities if true this method
could help
to identify and to differentiate new
oligoclonal or
severe clonal populations in patients
with neoplastic
malignancies
this slide is also shows the performance
of the alkaline phosphatase test in
combination
with c34 staining in
a second case that we also studied with
c34 positive alkaline height cells
at nine gausses and and relapse each
individual
circle represents c34 positive cells
with high expression levels
of alkaline phosphatase activity
pressure magnesium rich in primitive
and refractory cells comparisons of
well-defined
and cycle and circuit populations
consist
consisting of this c34 alkaline
cells provides valuable information at
the moment
of diagnosis and similarly at relapse
six months later
in order uh to evaluate the potential
role
of alkaline phosphatase positive cells
in lymphoma
we applied our methodology to a 12 year
old patient with a peripheral blood
immunophenotyping
compatible with the diagnosis of work
its
lymphoma to give together with a bone
marrow or spirit infiltration
plural effusion and ascites
with a 15 to 87 87
percent of ca 10 positive cd19 positive
cells
flow cytometry analysis of c c 10
positive
c 19 positive cells and
alkaline height positive lymphoma cells
found
were found in marrow as shown here
and also evident also evidencing and
increase
activity of alkaline phosphatase
positive cells in a side
in a in a sinus lymphoma cells that we
also
identify it
because uh central uh stem cell selects
a specific
cells so for surface markers the
identification of this compartment can
be difficult
making cancer stem cells especially
elusive
thus we undertook a prospective cohort
study based
on our previous work with the objective
to investigate whether
there might be differences in alkaline
phosphatase activity
within primitive leukemic cells and
its association with the potential risk
of recurrence and mortality
in newly diagnosed patients with acute
myeloid leukemia between 2015 and 2018 a
total of
106 patients were diagnosed with acute
myelo-delicious in our hospital
and after exclusion criteria criteria
[Music]
that we applied 43 eligible
patients were identified and included in
the overall
analysis briefly our saying
strategy uses dye cycle violet stain
a low cytotoxicity permeant a dna
specific dye that can be used for dna
content uh
cell cycle flow cytometry but also to
identify a very primitive
stem cell site like the site population
dictator violet can be excited
with violet lysor with violet
laser light and can be used for
simultaneously
simultaneous measurement with alkaline
phosphatase
with which is excited with blue
laser and its emission can be collected
using a
standard fluorescent filter subsequently
cells
were assigned with fluorophore
fluorophore conjugated
monoclonal antibodies and can be easily
analyzed
on the flow cytometer in in
this slide more detail is provided
provided to better
understand how the how we discriminate
alkaline phosphatase positive cells side
the scatter was detected using the
violet laser
and alkaline height positive cells
were simultaneously detected with
monoclonal antibodies that we selected
together classify
the lychemic essential compartment
p c 34 positive cells
this is phycology in uh c34 particles
positive cells were detected after uh
excitation with the yellow green laser
and the alkaline phosphatase lysis stain
was excited
again with a blue laser the improved
signal together with the fact that there
is no need for color compensation
results in the improved
immunophenotyping analysis of leukemic
cells by multiple or
flow cytometry two bone marrow aspirates
from
uh are compared in the same patient
displaying height levels of alkaline
phosphatase activity in combination
with c theory for the scenic and
diagnosis and
relapse
and we used a received
receiver operating characteristical
analysis
area under the curve sensitivity and
specific
specific specificity to measure
prognostic accuracy
of our test in predicting uh even free
survival
and the optimal cut of elu was
identified according to the yodan's
index to classify
patients into two groups according uh to
the two
twelve percent of alkaline phosphatase
and
life stain positive cells within the
blast population
that we detected using the previous
panel i will show you
in the previous slide univariate and
multivariate analysis were used to
identify
factors that are associated with overall
survival and even free
survival in patients with acute myeloid
leukemia
alkaline phosphatase expression was a
significant predictor
of overall survival on on univariate
analysis
alkaline phosphatase expression was a
significant predictor
of even free survival on univariate and
multivariate analysis
and in the univeriate cox model for
overall survival
age however level and intermediate risk
aml type and alkaline phosphatase group
were associated with a significant
impact of survival the only factor that
retained their significance on
multivariate analysis was age
and in the only ever overhead cox model
for even free survival
age favorable and intermediate risk and
the alkaline societies group
were associated with a significant
impact
on progression and relapse the only
factors that retained their significance
on multivariate analysis
were fibroall risk and the alkaline
phosphates
group and plots of
kaplan-major limit estimates of overall
survival
of acute myeloid leukemia and group
patients
are shown here and
rock curve allowed us to classify two
identifiable
i identify all identifiable
alkaline phosphates groups of patients
that diagnoses according
to the numbers of leukemic blood
expressing more than 12
or less than 12 percent of the alkaline
phosphates positive cells
these these are 27 patients in in group
a and less and with less
than just percent of how can you
facilities positive cells
16 patients in group b
as well as for the event-free survival
when classified by
the alkaline phosphatase
can you see here
cancer immunotherapy was was named
the science by science magazine that's
the breakthrough
of of the year and uh
more recently the nobel prize for
medicine and physiology was awarded to
gmail
and the super honjo in 2018
and cancer immunotherapy will cover the
last part
of my talk today
[Music]
in order to to advance or personalize in
medicine in oncology
pdl testing for antipedial one directed
immunotherapy
has emerged as a highly promising
biomarker pdl1
is one of the ligands for pd-1 it can be
expressed by two more cells
and may also be induced pdl1 tumors have
been shown
to be more likely to respond to
checkpoint blockade
however complexities exist because
too many antibodies and cutoffs use it
for video one and it is not a
perfectly predictive uh biomarker at the
present time
checkpoint antibody inhibitors are a
noble class of inhibitors that function
as a tumor suppressing factor via
modulation of immune cell tumor
cell interaction this checkpoint
blockers
are rapidly becoming a heckly promising
cancer therapeutic approaches that
yields remarkable and anti-tumor
responses with limited side effects
and despite the huge success and
efficacy of the
mtpd and therapy response it is
limited to specific types of cancer
which attributes to be which attributes
to the insufficient
and heterogeneous expression of pd1 in
the tumor
micro environment and
then three years ago i had the
opportunity to attend
this very exciting meeting
this scientific tutorial focused uh
on antibody validation for processometry
and many concerns were
raised about pvr one reactivity by
by the organizer but also by the
attendant
uh the prognostic value of video one has
been
has been controversial in in recent
studies and pdo one is
known to play a major role in
suppressing the immune response yet
increasing studies
have reported that people when
expression has a favorable pronastic
value for cancer patients this raises
the concern about how to understand
physiological
one expression and this table hike likes
the importance of perio one affinity
and it suggests that the reactive is the
reactive efficiency of pdl one
is more useful to predict the response
to
immunotherapy then we are able to
determine
whether pdl1 expression could predict
the prognosis
of newly diagnosed with multiple myeloma
and line cancer patients
and we decided to develop a highly
reproducible
i'm sorry for accurate scoring of pdl1
positive cells
we have validated a in-house atomic
assay
that can be performed on peripheral
blood and bone marrow
samples of diagnosis and this test can
be used as a guide for to predict
response to antivisible one directed
therapies
to target the pd-1 video pdl1 pathway
with therapeutic antibodies that are
directed at the p1 because it's wrapping
the pd-1
pdl1 pathway and with herpetic
antibodies
results in restoration of effector
immune responses against the tumor
because tiny biopsies can result in in
false negative perio one
evaluation we focus on the accurate
identification
of on peripheral blood myeloid and
derived
supersoft cells using flow cytometry and
our knowledge no wash methods
and as you can see here we can detect
the target
using a a specific antibody against
special one
and then then register
the fluorescence and collect all
the events on the floor cytometer
recent studies have shown that the
presence of
mildly derived suppressor cells in
multiple myeloma bone marrow
microenvironment
contributes to local suppression of the
immune responses
through the pdl1 pd1 pathway
this subset constitute constitutes a
heterogeneous population that expands
urine cancer
inflammation and infection playing a
critical role in the progression of
multiple myeloma and there is a growing
interest in this population as a
therapeutic target
for this disease the use of the
antipedia one pdf one monoclonal
antibodies in cancer patients might
represent a novel therapeutic
strategy and this study was aimed to
develop novel strategies to detect pl1
expression in mildly derived
suppressor cells another
controversial issue that was occurring
from the beginning is how to identify
these cells
the field of a myolate the rabbit
superstar cells research
is still immature and it's difficult to
distinguish these
cells from neutrophils and monocytes
and this slide shows mice and human
genotypes
but the exit the actual function of myo
the arrival super soft cells remains
still
controversial and myo
special cells are increased in multiple
myeloma
and lung cancer express c33
low or negative hla
dr are cd11b positive
and visual one positive and we also
decided to use a scheme or four lasers
like excitation to minimize
color compensation to provide the
optimal
screening of multiple myeloma biology
the rabbit suppressor cells because pdl1
expression may help to identify
patients most likely to respond to pd1
pdl pathway
inhibition alone or plus inhibition of
another pathway
here is displayed a representative known
lies in the voice protocol
for the screening of pdl1 myolit and
derived through personal states
your superior cells by combining the
cycle violet to discriminate nucleated
from
non-nucleated cells and a series of
markers
to finally identify monocytic and
polymorph nuclear
polymorphonuclear myolit and deriver
and your derivative suppression cells
evaluation of pdo one expression was
performed
in terms of cell numbers and antigenic
density comparisons
across stimulation and as you can see
here after a stimulation of video one
positive cells
were undetectable uh in
in in this in this patient
and changes in pdr1 expression after a
photovolester treatment with pma
found a series of patients with a
dramatic increase after a stimulation
compared with non-stimulated cells
suggesting that fall change in pdo1
appears to have an important regulatory
factor that may
that may relate to different in
underlying mechanisms
within a patient importantly pdo1 was
not found at cytoplasmic level
variation imperial one fall change among
patients led us to consider the
possibility that perio one does express
a cytoplasmic level and after
stimulation transfer cases translocated
to the cell membrane in the same man in
the same manner as cd11b
pdo1 and cd11b cytoplasmic levels were
symbols that simultaneously
studied in 11 patients and pdl1
was found to be undetectable at
cytoplasmic level in comparison
with cd11 be also a cytoplasmic
level for reactive antigen
and this slide shows the pr14 change in
a
series of 31 multiple myeloma patients
for change was calculated as a ratio
of number of stimulated and
non-assimilated and myo-derived
suppressor cells
pdl one positive and all patients
uh showered a white wall a white uh full
change variation
ranging from one which means no
variation
to 650 which means
a large variation
in this slide we can visualize the
molecular
mechanism of interaction between pd1 and
pdf1
and locate via your to the tiny
accessible area
of less than two angstroms competitive
experiments in
in presence of durawalmab who are also
performed in
in my lab and the pdl1 conjugate for
flow cytometry analysis confirm it near
identical target site
as we demonstrated with this kind of
competitive
experiment pdo1 is detected
differentially depending on the
stimulation time and the fact that the
pdl1 was not present at cytoplasmic
level
led us to investigate changes in pdl1
expression
over time and after a stimulation
pdl1 expression was found to be higher
after one to five minutes with a
progressive decrease
up to an hour
okay oops and this graph was used to
display the video all can the pdl one
kinetics in terms
of mean fluorescence intensity and
percentage of pdo one
positive cells psne
visualization methods helped us to
monitor that other phenotypic changes
did not occur
with the stimulation over time whereas
epidural one was the only marker
affected over time
as you can see here
and the following slides will show you
how pdo one is quickly changing
to the unfolded state after stimulation
you can see here this is one minute this
is
five minutes four minutes
up to the final slide completed
at 60 minutes
finally i would like to highlight our
more recent
publication demonstrating how video one
reactivity
appears to result from complex
iterations
interactions that can only be detected
with minimal sample
perturbation and using these no lies no
wash
methods in view of these conformational
properties
analysis of pathological
immunosuppressive myeloid derivations of
cells
could help to better understand and
overcome the mechanisms
of immunotherapy resistance by
developing new treatment
strategies i'd aimed at promoting pdo-1
stabilized and folded the states
altogether our findings may indicate the
need or
to find compounds that by themselves
exhibit a pma-like
effect agents at appropriate aggregating
this pathologically expanded manually
derived
superstar cell population and on not
only killing
the tumor cells in this slide a more
classic
display was used to monitor differential
physical one expression
before day zero and after immunotherapy
suggesting that the unfolded state can
be a novel mechanism
of resistance to cancer immunotherapy
as well as to show how immunotherapy
has little effect on the numbers of
pathologically expanded
modulate and derived suppressor cells
in summary panels of immunomotors in
combination with functional analysis
can provide more information than single
phenotype
our protocols allow and touch processing
of whole black
and bone marrow by simply adding reagent
or alternatively by collecting violet
vase
versus blue side scatter and
intrinsic cellular alkaline phosphates
activity
a diagnosis may be used to estimate
relapses
and disease persistence more accurately
our
immunotherapy study is a developed novel
strategies to detect to your one
expression
in both myo-derived and suppressable
cells suppressor cells to predict
antipedial one therapy success
and this uh pdo one
myomyolate-derived supervisor cells
which are increased in cancer patients
having important roles
in these immune suppressive functions
that we will need to clarify and control
by by decreasing this number
circulating in in peripheral black
finally i would like to thank my team
angelo
[Music]
i would like to to thank jolene bradford
and michael ward for providing the
support which allowed me
to undertake this research and for
the professional and personal uh
relationship over
the last nine years
thank you very much for your attention
and i will happy to take
some questions from the audience
thank you jordy for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
is pdl1 expression a biomarker for
patient selection
is pdl one really a predictive biomarker
oh thank you very much for this uh
interesting uh question um
i i want to say that is that we are
exploring um yeah video one
uh expression can be a a view marker
a biomarker for patients selection and
we are currently investigating
some cancer patients we have
started a prospective study
and we are exploring exploring the video
the video one expression using this no
lies no wash
method this functional uh analyzes in
in my lab just to try to determine if
the field one and this change in the
folding state can be
really a predictive a predictive
biomarker one one of the problem with
tumor cells is that in many occasions we
can receive very
tiny biopsy but we prefer to use this
non-invasive method just to
study the pd01 expression on on this
expanded on this pathologically expanded
myolith derived special cells
and i have no preliminary
data but i think that
i think that we will be able to obtain
uh
very nice information um not also
related as
a potential biomarker for patient
selection but also
for uh try to understand is some make if
specific or some mechanisms of immune
resistance can appear
thank you jordy our next question is
is there any physiological function for
alkaline phosphatase in normal stem
cells
well this is also a very
nice question i i my suspicion is that
the alkaline phosphatase plays a
in in the upcoming phosphates activity
or this enzyme
plays a key relevant role
in the bone marrow micro environment
i think that i have no demonstration
uh of this hypothesis but i believe that
the the ultimate phosphatase in normals
themselves is contributing
to uh to develop a more hypoxic niche
which is preferred for for this kind of
uh
for the more primitive healthy
stem cells and just to avoid a critical
differentiation to non-desired
lineages and just to preserve the whole
renewable
capability okay great thank you so much
jordy
our next question is
is pdl-1 involved in all human
malignancies
well we have this is very well described
and
it was a i was uh
explaining that in one of my slides that
this
the p01 expression is not related to or
or is not expressed in in all in all
tumors
it can be expressed in in solid tumors
but also in
in leukemia and uh we are especially
uh focused in in the in the beginning we
were especially
especially focused in multiple myeloma
but
immunotherapy was discontinued and
that's the main reason
because we are now um studying the pd01
expression uh in in myeloid uh
derived supercell cells from patients
with uh lung cancer but it can be
expanded to
to other to other than other other
cancers but always limited by
the pdl one expression in tumor cells
um uh i think that it it
it isn't necessary necessary to
highlight that uh
pdo one can be also expressed in the
myeloid uh
the rabbit superstar cells we which can
be expat
expanded in in in many human
malignancies
contributing to our tumor
proliferation and maybe this can be a
very
high hot topic not to
only study the the expression of video
one in tumor cells but also
studying the expression of pl1 in this
pathologically expanded population
thank you jordy looks like we have time
for a few more questions
our next question here is is alkaline
phosphatase the only available technique
to detect
cancer cells um
the answer is clear the answer is no
there are
many many methods uh in in
that were designed to identify
cancers themselves one one of the
of the methods that we prefer in my lab
is not only the outcome
facilities expression we also look at
the expression
of multi-drug transporters
and a different question is is if
this this technique it can be also used
to detect
cancer uh stem cells uh of course uh
this technique and the alkaline
phosphatase
can is available as others such as the
yellow floor
and other methods to detect cancer
uh stem cells and uh the cell calling
phosphatase
method takes advantage to to other
methods
that are market available in in the
market
because it's not uh if looked at by
multi-multi-track transporters
which are mainly uh which are mainly
which are over expressed
in in cancer can be over expressed in
cancer cells
but also in cancers themselves such as
the cytoplasm
with over expression of the abc g2
transporter
thank you jordy our last question is
is the alkaline phosphatase method
necessary or enough for a cancer
stem cell phenotype how is alkaline
phosphatase positivity defined
yeah i will start by by the second
question because
we were reanalyzing
the values that we obtained in our
cohort or 43 patients we with acute
myeloid leukemia
and we can use the
ratio between positive and negative
blastic cells by comparing the alkaline
phosphates activity
and and not only the 12 percent
um i think it works uh very well
when comparison with the cutoff that we
obtained using the rock
core uh analyzes the the ratio
between alkaline height and alkaline law
positive cells appears to be a reliable
method to discriminate um
this positivity in within the the
chemical stem cell population
and um related to the first question uh
if alkaline phosphatase method is
necessary
or not for a cancer stem cell
phenotype uh i think that this method
can be
complementary and one of the main
advantages of using the alkaline for
this staining is that we are
detecting a very rare fraction that
cannot be identified by using
a phenotype but we can combine this
fluorescence coming from the activity of
the enzyme with many many other
antibodies but also with other
fluorescent pros
to better define the cancer
stem cell population and this takes
advantage because we can
isolate by by cell sorting these
populations
and then perform a single uh
single single cell sequencing and they
use a study gene expression analysis of
the
the cells that we are isolating and this
i think that this can be a very nice
tool that um
in the future research will need to
clarify
uh how uh these uh cancers of stem cells
are expressing
at this um this uh this enzyme
at higher level uh there is a
approach that we also developed in in my
lab
because we were studying astrocytomas
and biomass and we were interested in
identifying the site population and
we observed that under hypoxic
conditions
the number of cyclic pollution cells
increased but also increased the number
of alkaline phosphatase
positive positive cells or alkaline
phosphatase high cells within the site
population indicate indicating that
uh we are reaching in in more primitive
site population um cyclopation cells not
only by the classic
classical uh multi-drug resistance
efflux of the hdi or dicycle diode but
also confirmed by
uh this increase in the and the and the
output process activity
thank you again jordy for your time
today and for your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye